hi there steve kaufman here i haven't
done one of these videos in a while
uh i've been traveling some of you may
know that if you followed my
adventures i was in vienna
in slovakia
trying to ski where there was no snow
and then traveled in the czech republic
at a phenomenal time got to use a bit of
my check
i have announced the 90-day challenge so
i thought i would provide a little bit
of background the 90-day challenge
starts on january the 15th
uh i am going to devote myself to
learning korean with a little more
system and discipline than i normally do
i'm going to focus i'm going to make a
special effort to
achieve a degree of intensity in my
study of korean
i'm going to do this for a variety of
reasons first of all because korean has
kind of been kicking around with me
perhaps six years ago i did for about
six months i listened and i read and i
bought whatever books i could find
then i lost interest because there was
no interesting content
excuse me so i got into russian and then
subsequently czech and romanian and
brushed up my you know portuguese and
basically left korean alone
then uh probably a year ago i
put some more effort into korean
but my korean really isn't anywhere and
i feel
you know if i talk to people i can say
the few things that i can say and then i
don't understand very well what they say
back at me i kind of understand the
basic grammatical structure but i have
trouble using
the structure and the biggest thing as
is always the case i don't have enough
vocabulary so i like to
listen to and read things that are
meaningful of interest to me and i can't
do that so
in three months i hope to take myself
from what i think is roughly a
high beginner to a solid intermediate i
might even go for the
topic
uh exam in korean but
i'm not going to do anything on korea
until january the 15th so i don't know
much about it except that one of the
people commenting here said are you
going to take the topic exam which is
the test of proficiency in korean i may
just do that
but i don't know yet so
the some people have said well is this
like the plus one challenge
that
i think his name is brian kwong is doing
or is this like benny with his three
months to fluency
and i think there are other challenges
out there
and of course there are similarities
because it's all about learning
languages
uh three months or 90 days is a handy
period of time
um however uh i i i must admit i haven't
i haven't really looked at very
carefully
what benny does in his 30 days or in his
three months rather what brian kwong's
plus one consists of i had a a brief
look there are a bunch of questions
about goals and rewards and
and punishments or something and this
kind of
here's what we're doing okay
all i really want to do is step up my
level of activity
uh i'm not promising myself any specific
results
and i'm inviting other people to do the
same and
just by being more active with the
language being a little more disciplined
developing some habits
um
we inevitably learn more
and i'm going to try to be more
disciplined for example i'm looking for
a
an app that will track
my use of time because i say i study an
hour a day i think i probably study more
than an hour a day because typically
i'll read a bit in the morning if i'm in
the car
it could be 45 minutes to an hour then i
wash the dishes all the time i'm
listening and then i might do some
linking at night so probably closer to
two hours i want to find out exactly how
much time i spend and i think that will
be an inducement to be more systematic
in spending that time
uh
so those are the kinds of things that
i'm going to be doing and i'm going to
be sharing this and you know resources
for for korean i gave up on korean
because there were no interesting
resources a lot of resources have been
added to our library at link in korean
i'm going to use those but i'm also
going to look for others i may end up
asking people to record stuff for me and
i can share that with you so
but other people will be doing other
languages and they may be starting from
scratch or like me they may be
you know sort of stagnant in a level in
a language and they want to make a
breakthrough so the motives could be
will be varied the amount of time that
people have to spend will be varied
uh
but
you know it's not about speaking from
day one
if anything as you know i am more of an
input based learner link is structured
around the idea that the most efficient
way of learning a language is to expose
yourself to the language to meaningful
content that's
not too difficult for you and to acquire
vocabulary and to let your brain become
familiar with the language and the more
intensively you do this and this is what
happened to me when i was learning
mandarin i did so much listening and
reading that i ended up learning faster
than the others who may have been more
into
speaking finding other learners to talk
to
which
for people who like to do that that's
fine but i don't believe in that and i
think even when you are
say
speaking early
most of the benefit there is that you
are listening
and uh it is true and i often refer to
sort of the resonance of different
language learning situations and a real
situation face to face is higher
resonance than listening to an mp3
player however
if you have a very limited vocabulary
and can't say much then at the end of
half an hour you haven't been exposed to
very much of the language so in that
situation
at an early stage i prefer to listen and
read because it's a
richer language environment and then
when i am able to defend myself a little
better then i can have more meaningful
conversation so with regard to my korean
for example i'll be focusing on a lot of
listening and reading to get my
comprehension skills up improve my
vocabulary and then eventually i'll be
stepping up the speaking because the
speaking is more real it's higher
resonance i mentioned for example i was
in
czech republic in slovakia i was with my
wife and my son and his family so i
couldn't speak that much czech
all day long but just being in the real
environment uh people are speaking the
language in stores in little
interactions that you have with people
then newspaper and so forth
uh
there's something about that real
environment that that really makes any
interaction
resonate more
so therefore face-to-face is extremely
important
but there's a trade-off between the sort
of substance
uh the sort of richness of the language
exchange and this realia or the real
nature of the exchange
so i'm gonna be balancing those as i do
my
my korean
one thing i also wanted to say
you know i'm not starting from scratch
but for those of you who are starting
from scratch
in the 90 day challenge just a few bits
of advice for someone starting from
scratch
the big thing as i always repeat this
language learning is attitude time with
the language and learning to notice
so
one of the problems people have with
let's say french let's say they're
starting into french okay right off the
bat you have to notice that there are a
lot of
consonants you know letters in french
that aren't pronounced
that's just what it is there's no point
in reacting negatively to it and saying
this is stupid or you know it's
difficult it just is the x isn't
pronounced and it drags on as an s you
know
is the x isn't pronounced um
but if you say uh okay
or noel
but
i'm trying to think of uh
if it was
or spies
you know as it drags on so they have all
these uh
connecting sounds like
panna in the for example
part 2.
you don't know which one has the s and
which one doesn't
and and you won't be able to really even
if you study it it won't stick you just
have to accept the fact that just
recognize that it's there have a
positive attitude towards it and realize
that with enough exposure over a long
enough period of time and with
sufficiently intense exposure it'll
start to make sense so
to point
and then
and the nt at the end isn't pronounced
unless of course it's followed by vowel
in which case
the t gets pronounced and these are
things that it's like the russian thing
someone told me you know that uh
you know
one of something is in the nominative
singular two three and four is in the
genitive singular and five and more is
in the generally plural it you can't
absorb that kind of information
all you can sort of register is that
these words change
and watch for it so you're you're being
attentive you're trying to notice what's
happening and you're not resisting it so
you've got an open mind you've got a
good attitude and you want to learn it
and you're spending the time
and and if you do that enough and
occasionally review the rules without
trying to nail them down you have to be
confident that you're going to learn
so
i kind of introduced that because the
main thing is the 90-day challenge is to
step up our level of activity and that
is what we measure at link we don't
measure
where you are achievements level you
know
framework of reference
b2 it's how active are you how much are
you reading how much are you listening
how much are you linking in other words
saving words and phrases to your
database and if you step up that level
of activity you will do better i can
guarantee you that it's been my
experience over you know many many years
of learning many languages
step up your level of activity
interact with the language have a
positive and open and enthusiastic
emotionally committed attitude and
notice what's there
without necessarily hoping to nail it
down
and if we can do those things in the
90-day challenge then i think
all the participants are going to
benefit
so just a little further and if you have
any questions on the 90d challenge
please ask me and i can assure you i'm
still working on my russian in czech i'm
not going to start my korean until
january the 15th all right then
join the 90-day challenge
bye for now